I hate pranks.
I hate prank videos, prank shows,
I hate. .
what pranks have become in our society.
Especially nowadays,
because people think,
"It was a prank.
Not a rape,
so don't you tell anyone I raped you."
Pranks..have become
this..excuse
to act like an asshole.
Look at me, destroying the property
of this store
and inconveniencing its employees and customers!
Look at me,
look at my dick,
don't look at my camera buddy filmin' all this.
Look at me,
trying to get punched in the face for views!
Come on, punch me in the face
so I can get paid!
They're not silly or harmless or funny anymore, like,
"WHAT YEAR IS IT?!"
No, now you destroy shit.
Look at me!
Now you harass people.
Now you're an asshole.
Look at my asshole!
And I'm not talking about like,
pranks that you do with your friends and family
where you know it's all groovy.
I'm talking about we as a culture,
have come to accept
that it is okay to humiliate strangers and film them,
or like vandalize shit, and say it's okay
because it's a prank.
Or sexually harass women on the street.
That, to me,
is stupid.
If you're gonna do pranks,
get creative with it.
Do something that's really entertaining,
that's not shocking or mean or offensive.
You know?
Do something that you wouldn't mind done to you
or members of your family.
Someone asked me to thank today's sponsor
in an old lady voice, so here we go.
(frail voice) I'd like to thank Audible.com
for sponsoring today's episode.
You can go to audible.com/anna
for a free audiobook of your choice.
Currently, I'm listening to Gone Girl,
because I love me some Ben Affleck!
You can get that or another
free audiobook of your choice,
over at audible.com/anna.
That's audible.com/anna.
Now would you like a holiday cookie for Christmas?
(normal) Mmm.
I'll see you next week.
You stay awesome, Gotham.
This good.
That's real good.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara